okay so today is the strategy class so I
thought we'd go over improving your
pieces which can mean a lot of different
things it could be finding your worst
place piece and trying to find a better
square for it which okay when we're
talking about Knights usually we're
looking for an ideal square some nice
outpost where they'll be really good in
your opponent's won't be able to trade
for them we talked about bishops we're
talking about finding good diagonals
rooks good open files and we'll just
we'll get right to it so you can kind of
see the first one we'll jump into this
position right here if this is the first
one so this is the the game a game
between Raphael began ian versus
vladimir Akopian not version Akopian
who's who's lectured here 70 times but
vladimir Akopian so no affiliation to
the club and in this position we'll get
we'll show you the first couple moves
that were played in this position here
and now black adopted a set up with b6
the idea is to put the bishop on b7 play
moves like a6 b5 and ultimately c5 to
open up the diagonal for the bishop so
that's what white is playing for so
white found a way to stop him from doing
that so after a few more moves here
the bishop voluntarily went back to d3
with the idea of going to e4 that's one
way to prevent c5 because now there's a
pin and after this move we'll stop here
for a few minutes and it's it's a little
bit different when you're doing sort of
a strategy puzzle than a tactics puzzle
because when you do a tactics puzzle
there's one right answer sometimes
there's multiple but a good technical
izl has one right answer
and you know it's either you know the
winning move or a losing move and so you
get the instant satisfaction when you
solve it of okay that's the correct
answer
well for these there may be more than
one move that doesn't truly change the
valuation of the position substantially
but it is worth trying to figure out
what moves they came up with in the game
so in this position white found a way to
a Rhema new ver one of his pieces and he
found a good square for it so so we're
not looking for like some huge tactical
blow it's not Bishop takes g6 and
checkmate
it's a just sort of a slower maneuvering
type puzzle and so I've showed it to two
of the I guess they are the two
highest-rated other instructors that we
have here that work for the club and
they both came up with the same answer
here that's just wrong
so I so I'm looking at the Class A and B
players to give me the first wrong
answer here all right excellent
so yeah the answer what was your first
move again though sorry okay so this is
sort of your your idea mm-hmm which is
sort of the the right idea c5 is the
square that we're looking for I wonder
if there's some way if you move this
Knight for me to take advantage of the
fact that now this guy is not defended
because now I'm attacking this mm-hmm
yeah so I get to play a four then I'm
I'm looking pretty good so this is sort
of the right idea but this is not our
you know worst place piece if we look at
all the pieces individually it's the
right idea but uh not the right piece
this guy has a useful job here excellent
yeah and that's that's what was played
night to be one yeah so uh a subtle
retreat and after that you make your way
to c5 I'll show you the mistake that was
made by our fellow instructors here they
had the idea of moving the bishop so say
Bishop to be one with the idea of going
to d6 which would be an excellent square
except for you've allowed black to play
the move c5 and if I play C five your
Center falls apart because I'm taking
here and then this guy becomes weak so
you'll never get your Knight to d6 and
even if you do I'll have some tactical
tricks like Knight takes and then Queen
takes your knight etc but okay we've hit
upon the right move here Knight to be
one also we have a threat now on c6 we
got two pieces attacking it otherwise
you may have time to play moves like a
five and a four but since we we gained a
tempo by attacking the C pawn after you
defend it Knight to d2 and we're on our
way and okay the game continued as such
and here white has a slight but evident
advantage he didn't allow his opponent
to play c6 and black left to spend some
time trying to get rid of this pesky
rope he's going to play moves like this
and move his Queen but so out of the
opening white got a slight advantage
obviously not as quite as satisfying as
you know a tactical checkmate but uh
these are the kinds of slow maneuvers
that I think people really struggle to
find in their own game so people are
always saying you know what should I do
in the middle game
in its strategy its planning it's
improving your peace here the night okay
he looks kind of good on c3 but what is
he really doing he doesn't seem to have
much of a future
obviously c5 a much better square for
the night okay we'll go to our second
example here
and if you're just joining us we're
doing puzzles where we improve our
pieces so it's sort of slow maneuvering
tonight and in this position it's it's
blacks turn it will show a few moves see
we can get an idea of the plot after h5
white played a four planning to restrict
the night over here and after King h7 he
also plans to restrict the knight on f6
which is a good idea when you have more
space he's trying to cramp all the black
pieces so black runs out of moves but
now black went back white is thinking
perhaps of making use of the H file so
even though we just went to h7 now that
the H file is open make sense to retreat
and now after a5 we'll pause here for a
few minutes and we'll give you a chance
to see if you can improve your position
improve when you're your worst place
pieces today and then we'll ask first
which of your pieces are not very well
placed that's a good way to go way to
start
ok so correct yeah the knight on D 7
he's not looking too good he doesn't
have a huge future or so it would appear
anybody else you had the bishop yeah so
yeah so we got two bad pieces here yeah
this guy he's not bad uh in the future
hopefully we'll get to double on the C
file so yeah at the moment he's you know
he's not the best so I mean you might be
thinking just some plan like this but
okay y can also contest the C file
it's a plan yeah it's about formulating
a plan it's you know it's not some
winning move and it's not just one move
it's it's really a plan all right Queen
c7 with the idea of going to c4 okay
presumably I'll put one of these rooks
here let's go with this guy and then you
want it to go here does your plan right
and you're leading with your you're
queen
so maybe in the future I'll be able to
use this the square I'll get an attack
on your queen and I'll be able to use
one of these squares or or I'll just not
move my knight so not quite it says for
the sake of argument able please diode a
c3 yes this is a tactical possibility
that does work in the position and you
see the follow-up days the five yes
excellent and if I take which I don't
have to yeah you play here with a
discovered attack and so yeah when I
when I first saw this this is one of the
things that I thought about and white
has to play the right move here yeah so
it's quite good that you found this and
then I thought okay well the Queen has
to go move somewhere and we take this
rook but there's actually this move
which should lead to an equal position
you can attack the Queen I can go here
and you can either trade first or take
this guy and the position is actually
equal so this is a very good solution in
the game a more strategical solution was
found I'll give you a hint as to what
happened in the game because obviously
there's if there's yeah nine h7 and okay
we'll give you White's move and you see
the idea excellent yeah Bishop f6 to g5
getting rid of the bad bishop and so
this game turned around pretty quickly
from this point things should be pretty
level here but after this way quickly
made a few mistakes so in this position
a very nice move here by black
Bishop f4 just creeping in now the g5
square is available for the tank and
okay white probably didn't lose with
this next move but he made it really
difficult on himself he traded the
bishop which is strategically rather
dubious because now the knight jumps
into e5 and suddenly Black has a
tremendous position as long as you don't
get forked on b6 then you're and you're
doing pretty good so here all of a
sudden it's black that turns out to be
better so he went from slightly worse to
better just with the idea of getting rid
of one of his poorly placed pieces which
is a another thing that you want to do
with your pieces when you have a bad
piece and they have a good piece he's
controlling some really nice dark
squares here you know particularly b6
you can you can try to trade it because
this guy isn't doing a whole lot for you
on g7 so excellent any questions about
this one all right so this is the game
between you haenyeo zapatos and edwin
bend from venice 1953 and so here black
decided to play on the queenside and
soon they they locked up the position
and now a four or a five excuse me and
then after a few more moves black is
trying to prevent white from ever
playing moves like a four and after this
move we will pause and so again we're
looking for a plan so it's not just a
single mover or sequence of moves it's
it's a plan to improve the position for
black
oK we've identified this guy he's there
to prevent a for but yes obviously it's
we got a lot of ponds here on light
squares so that's that's very good the
idea that was played that was uh was
very nice and this was something that
happened to me in a game so the way I
was able to search for this puzzle was I
remember I was playing a game against a
priyadarshan canna pan comes to club
regularly very strong I am I'll probably
be a GM pretty soon he played this
maneuver and once he played the first
move I thought I was doing well you know
nice equal position kind of like this or
whatever and then he played one movement
I was like oh it's unfortunate that's
unfortunate so I quite like this idea
there's a whole bunch of plans that do
make sense that you could come up with
I'll show you what happened in the game
yes it's very tricky yeah it has
tell you what pieces okay it has you
everybody so far has been okay here's
the hint everybody's been playing so far
on the kingside but black actually has a
way to improve on the queenside
which is yeah the cyber is more space
did you see that coming did you see that
coming
what is it this is the most suggested
move and it's okay I can play here the
point is now even if your bishop comes
back you you never really have any good
place to go and then I'd hate to tell
you what the best move is over here
because then I'd be preventing the
threat that we haven't found yet
so if you take immediately okay I mean
we can share we can share the a file I
don't mind sharing night still has
nowhere to go
okay so we're quite preoccupied with
this night but uh okay happy how can we
so this is the right idea we would we
would love to be able to take care but
the problem is we're sharing the a file
we don't want to share yeah excellent
yeah so what's the first move Roque six
and we can open the a file anytime we
want so we can just build and build we
can triple on the a file which is a very
powerful plan in this position and okay
indeed white sort of conceded that he
has no chance and he got off the the
file because okay really there is no
chance we can we can triple up and you
you get into trouble and now simply by
taking and dropping the rope in black is
much better every day do this lecture
yeah I might just do I might just do the
same puzzles all right what's up blaze
I'm coming in you got your Panda you
want to come sit in the front you want
to watch the class where do you want to
sit up here right in front of the camera
if you sit over here you can see the big
screen you can sit right here right up
in the front and here black could play
the simple move g6 and okay he came up
with a sacrifice that's okay he decided
to sacrifice here which is also good for
black he could have played simpler he
kind of made it complicated but he did
go on to win this game so with that in
mind we'll jump to our fourth puzzle
uh-uh let's go
it was actually a Dutch okay
yeah I'm bashful schooled us yes
mmm this is sorta yeah it does yeah it's
the French pawn structure and we got the
move F Ivan how did blackwell in French
is good yeah okay so now the thing we're
on this one
okay now this one is very very nice I
quite like this one it's a very
beautiful idea this is a French this is
truly a French it's a winner where and
here black played to move b6 with the
idea of playing Bishop to a6 Bishop to
d3 is a sort of the typical thing so
white had a way to counteract this
attack here after Bishop b5 check he
interfered with blacks plan and now he
drops back to d3 and sort of an
important move here
Bishop to a4 so not only do you have
sort of the idea that at some point we
can play see for and if your Queen goes
away okay you got to worry about this
pawn but also you're preventing white
from playing a for himself which he
tends to do in these positions he plays
a4 and Bishop to a3 and get some
pressure along that diagonal so that's
that's typically how you can gain a
little bit more space over there so this
just prevents that idea altogether and
after h4 he has some aggressive
intentions let's let's not castle
instead h6 and after here he pushes the
bishop away and now we pause and at the
time of this game this was a novelty
this is the first time this idea I ever
occurred on the board now it's become a
part of theory so if we have any win
over specialists in here perhaps you
know this idea this position has
occurred now in more than 100 games so
we're still in opening theory
but okay the idea is quite beautiful so
it deserves to be shown if you don't
just know it right off the bat it's it's
quite difficult to to conceptualize this
but if you imagine picking up your
pieces and putting them on ideal squares
then perhaps you'd be able to find the
slope so is there really three things I
was considered probably key 7 Queen g8
creation Wow Wow very good very good
yeah King d7 with the idea of Queen g8
and Queen h7 which did indeed happen
fantastic stuff yes fantastic stuff so
here he defended with the rooks you play
this variation now you know you play it
as black or white plane is black now you
know yeah this is the big maneuver and
now again there's a there's more ways to
maneuver as pieces at this also is a
nice move the bishop comes here in the
future it might go to b5 even more
pressure on the Queen side and now the
rook is prepared to swing over either to
g8 or f8 and he's going to start opening
up the King side and so ok black is is
just controlling all sides of the board
here in the game he went to f8 and
pretty soon he was able to open up the
king side and okay is a good attack
because he got all of his pieces over
there so and again it's not rewarding
when okay you didn't just instantly win
but it's just that the very idea of
moving the king out of the way and
swinging the Queen all the way over to
h7 is very pretty to look at so
yes excellent yeah yeah perfectly safe
from the center because it's it's so
closed unless you're Mike comer you're
really worried about this pin but
there's there's nothing there
sure yeah we can go back we can take a
look at the whole opening here okay so
we got the winner where so this is still
the main line and then you do you do
funny stuff here don't you do like funny
stuff here is it here I started playing
the poison online hmm
I love it as both sides yeah been
playing a lot okay yeah queen a5u
salutely on a four yeah yeah you can you
can do you can do this so like in our
game the bishop went to a four well you
can also put a queen there and it's kind
of annoying hmm
okay so here yeah here's how we got to
this position the differential Lautner's
yeah I mean it it seems typical enough
cuz yeah you want to just trade these
bishops and you just haven't seen that
idea yeah it's not the most common line
it's not the main line this this isn't
chess openings explained so we'll try to
okay so now all right all right getting
a few more people in here okay so this
is the game this is our last example
here for the day between Darcy Lima and
francisco jose dos Santos I was played
in Brazil in 2001 all right and in this
position white played a five and so
suddenly we see that the King side has
been shut down
so the Queen sides been shut down so all
of the action is going to happen over on
the Kings side so white quickly began to
prepares his troopers over there and
okay this also could have been part of
the maneuvering lecture okay we bring
our knight back over for where he's in
the action
and now it is sort of a waiting game we
can play at some point if I was going to
make progress he's going to play the
move f5 but we we can also just do
nothing for a long time keep the
position equal and at just the right
point the only pawn break left is at
five so it is a 2500 player playing a
2,200 player so presumably he's he's
thinking about winning here and he's a
little bit better he has more space on
that side so they played a few more slow
moves and we'll pause here this is the
last last example and we'll see how
would you guys improve the position and
again all I'll give you a minute and
then I'll ask you first which is the
worst placed white piece and then we'll
see if we can find the solution the
night is not bad and we're going to play
s5 at some point so that seems like the
right square for the night you get the
Knight to f4 somehow okay you're gonna
go here sack upon and then go here you
met you were just gonna take it as white
as black you just lasix as white you
play a 6 ok and it might might you might
take that eventually so it's it's white
to move and so here again we want the
plan we're looking for and in this case
you'll be a bit more satisfying because
it is sort of a winning plan because
we're obviously much better in this
position just how are we going to make
progress see you weigh 1 B 3 and then C
g5
ok so you're trying to put your night
here on c5 mm-hmm ok which not a bad
plan at all the should be it should be
perfectly fine yeah it's a good place it
doesn't help with the f5 push but ok you
are putting some pressure here on the e
pawn so certainly not a bad eye
and it would be even funnier if he did
this having already done this and then
it would be funny we could do all this
you know we could go right back yeah we
could go right back maybe I would be
nice little bit hey I saw I'll ask what
do you think White's worst place pieces
in this position the King yeah so we're
trying to play f5 and then the King side
will open wide up so you can imagine if
we just you know went for it a bit
hastily and when you take here you know
there's going to be some pressure down
the G file so okay we're let's let's
just pick them up let's pick them up
where would we would we want to put this
guy because yeah b2 or b3 excellent yeah
so yeah the King goes on a walk and he
he ends up on b3 we got plenty of time
you know there's there's no way for
black to make any progress here he's
just waiting so white has all the time
in the world and there goes the king
there he goes okay and black is just
waiting and you'll notice white is very
very very patient in this game because
why not you got all day so also we have
to worry about this this weakness and a
lot of lines that'll be significant so
here okay a lot of slow moves all these
moves are find it doesn't change the
evaluation both sides are just kind of
waiting we attack the H pawn and here we
provoke you to play the move g5
so now we push and now white once again
will very carefully reposition all of
his pieces so okay and we're just we're
just waiting white is very calm very
patient all sorts of all sorts of
waiting and this is funny too okay now
that the file is going to open up maybe
some heavy pieces are gonna be traded
maybe I'll even get my King a little
closer alright I'll come back
alright now it's a bit safer and we know
which file is going to open up we know
some heaven pieces are gonna be traded
if there's an end game maybe I want my
King a little bit closer and now black
takes which you shouldn't do anything
although white is ready to play here
which is pretty good for him and he must
play this at some point he's just
probably going to wait close to fifty
moves and you might as well because
maybe your opponent will do something
you know and if you doing something is
wrong then you should you should wait
for your opponent's to do it and so
eventually it happened and black tried
to do something and okay now we have two
pawns with which we can push forward I
will just show the end of the game just
because it's nice
okay there's there's two ways to take
but let's take with a pond now we we
have lots of past ponds this is this is
trouble and okay this also is a nice
finish here in this position we want to
be able to push our Jeep on so we need
to get the Queen out of the way and here
black resigned once the Queen's come off
the board three passed pawns is is going
to be significant we're going to start
pushing this guy we're pushing all of
our pawns so black it had enough of the
torture it really was you're just
getting tortured there for the last
twenty four thirty moves okay so a
fairly impressive idea and that's worth
noting that even your king can sometimes
be improved especially when one side is
closed and the other side is about to
open it also it happens occasionally to
in the the Kings Indian defense your
your eyes white your King is on the
inside and perhaps the queenside is
closed and you're about to launch an
attack but before you do that maybe you
have time to run your King all the way
over to the other side assuming your
opponent has no way to make any progress
all right all right so that's it for the
examples but we do have a little bit
more here so we have a game that was
sent in it's been nice of you and kind
of inundated with requests lately I got
about 20 I'd say this week so last week
we went over some of them I wasn't
filmed so so sorry if that was that was
you I'm trying to get to all of them but
uh you can keep sending in your quest
info at st. Louis chess club org and
I'll try to take the best ones the most
destructive ones and show them here yeah
I just can't it can't do all the
requests this one comes all the way from
the Netherlands from a guy whose name I
hope is pronounced hice but I have no
chance I'll speak Dutch oh it's GI Jas
he said some really nice things he wrote
like mountains of paragraphs which is
funny everyone from every other country
like when it's a foreign country they
write like all these paragraphs and all
this nice stuff and then like when in
American right side it's like here's my
game dude like can you analyze this it's
like so you know you know when I see
this I'm like oh it must be foreign
which is excellent we love it I'll just
I'll mention some of the things that he
said I wish to express my thanks for all
the work that's been put into your
YouTube channel is highly informative
between the running jokes with props
with mr. taunts the sarcasm of GM Ben
Feingold the storytelling of GM Yasser
Serra Juan the enthusiasm of Mike comer
and the creativity of Eve brings to
chess there's so much to like I could go
on about all the others too but let's
end it with a special thanks to Ben
Simon for all the great
yeah big yeah big props big props from
the Netherlands okay excellent so this
let's see what he I guess I don't have
what he said about this this game on my
page here but oh he played a game on
like chess and he said this was the
highest rated opponent that he's ever
beaten so he's playing an opponent rated
2,300 on my chess high-seas rating is
1900 but i don't know how indicative
that that really is of his rating he
played very well in this game so let's
let's go ahead and we'll we'll take a
look I believe was game 45 and I'll
accept all these nice diagram like hey
it's guy he really tried you got to
really try it a 15 minutes with a
60-second increment so and yeah I think
he also sent in a game this was a second
submission he said didn't game does like
45 minutes so it is a longer game he's
trying he's likes to think I guess he
likes to play a lot of classical time
controls so very good we'll take a look
all right
he's black so we got the Pierce alright
not the opening that I would I would
recommend especially to beginners you do
obviously you let white have as much
space as he he can desire but okay
haven't seen this game it's it suited
for players that like to counter-attack
and now the Austrian attack so White's
most ambitious and aggressive way of
meeting the periods and so we get some
standard moves and then there's huge
bodies of theory for both castling and
c5 in this position in this game he
chose the move c5 and I believe it's
here white already makes a very
suspicious move sorry so here a 5 was
played in now a slightly dubious move h4
you have this promising piece sacrifice
in this line where you sacrifice a whole
night so this has been played several
times it you know requires the black is
already castled so that is perhaps what
his opponent was thinking because that
is you know a very aggressive way to
play as white
but since we haven't castled you know h5
and taking on g6 isn't really a big
threat and here I think black
overreacted he just played the move h5 I
don't see any reason not to take here h5
is not a threat I just take your night
and I'm winning and white doesn't even
really have a great way to take back if
you take back with the Queen
I play knight c6 I take on e5 same if
you take with your night I take on e5
and ok I'm catching up in development so
I think if you just take here on d4 and
suddenly it's I mean Black is already
better but as it were h5 and now white
found a really strong powerful move here
very aggressive ecigs yeah this is this
is a very strong move so after we we
captured there's a couple good moves
but uh yeah Bishop to d3 and ok 9 f8 was
played
ok so we're up upon obviously the the C
pawn can be taken and okay it feels it
feels pretty comfortable for white here
I think I'd quite like to have the white
pieces I'd get these guys out and Castle
queenside and in the game I think even
in this position white put is queen Ani
- perhaps more accurate is is just to
play Bishop to e3 occasionally even
though it looks dreadful black can think
about taking this pawn so ok I think it
makes sense to have the fish up here and
I don't know the Queen might go to e2
the Queen might go to d2 so I think
would be a little bit more flexible to
begin by moving the bishop first but as
it where he got his Queen out to e2 and
so again I think here is there's a move
I didn't like I guess I'm just thinking
about not getting checkmated as black so
Bishop d7 and then Queen maybe to a5
maybe to c7 and long castles looks like
the safest plan for black instead he
played the movie
five now White has a lot of pieces
developed and black doesn't in this you
know this sort of looks a bit clumsy so
it's white that really wants to open the
position here so I think in this
position to what was what is that
and white just castled but I think also
very reasonable is just open it up you
want to open it up I'll open it up and
obviously you know we can we can take
care a couple times but yeah quite I
still quite like white you know we have
you know good squares for this guy and
we're going over here sometimes we're
taking here in Bishop c5 yeah it's just
yeah that's just just good all right but
uh as it where he castled so okay
obviously he's not worried about you
taking on f4 that helps him develop his
bishop but so part of this point though
of the movie five once you get to get
the bishop out okay so he found a good
square for his Bishop it's very good and
again what should be opening everything
up as fast as possible because at each
you know it's black and still at least
two moves away from castling so here
which is which is fine
but now he takes this way he can get a
much stronger attack after taking first
here and then here
opening up the game as fast as possible
and okay this this again okay this would
be a variation that also favors white so
he took this way
and in black castled also interesting is
taking here I don't you know care so
much about the pond but this actually is
a good way to keep the position closed
so here I'm taking now with the idea of
of getting the material but I'm trying
to keep the position closed and all
Castle queenside on the next move this
also was an idea said he castled okay
let's let's open it up and I think white
again missed missed a chance here
he played King h1 which is a better
square now I mean nothing bad is is ever
going to happen on this diagonal like
I'm not going to take your night and
then for Q so okay so it's a slightly
better Square but after a move like
Bishop g5 white gets all of his pieces
out very very quickly we bring our rooks
to the center the knight can jump in
here
you know this yeah you know this is just
good for white so King h1 and alright I
think this was a very good decision
we can't just babysit the g6 pawn for
the rest of our life that pawn isn't
very significant black needs to get all
this pieces out he needs to prioritize
development and coming up with a way
with getting all of his pieces into the
game if you don't play this then your
rook on h8 is just kind of trapped out
of the game for a long time so I think
it was a very smart decision and we're
looking at some pretty good squares here
you know we're going to go here we can
put a rook here we can go here these are
the sort of ideas that black has just
getting activity so that's very good he
took and rook h2 f8
this this pin is moderately annoying
and after here I think again black Plata
in inaccuracy but a decent move and the
game is night went to f4 but can anyone
suggest a better move
night where b5
d5 Knight d5 as black should I turn the
volume up in Simon so you can hear it
you'd love it
alright this just for you oh did you did
you mean d4 d5 yeah it should be this
should be pretty good yeah I think
that's a nice active square I'm also
good is here
you know exploiting the pin so yeah you
there are some ways to to exploit the
pin and get a pretty good position here
and okay it was okay I guess we can go a
little bit farther so now we are
threatening in this position we're to
take here we can take with youth of the
night or the bishop and then follow it
up with with rook takes so if say you
get out of the pin like like so okay
you've got to stay where you're
protecting f3 so this is the only place
you can go without you know dropping
upon on f3 well now we take and we play
Bishop to e5
and I mean Queen ji to Bishop h3 and if
you if you push here you know I can I
can drop back I can probably just take
this and I've really gotten rid of sort
of my problems and I don't think like
has any serious issues in this position
anymore in the game he went to f4 not a
bad spot at all and okay is white I
would probably move this Bishop I'm
looking at this pen by him here I assume
any square that's that safe is probably
very reasonable for this this Bishop but
he took here which is a mistake and now
like a like a good Pierce player black
showed his his tactical ability so I
throw it over to the audience now this
is a very nice sequence the next next
few moves here will challenge the
audience and perhaps black had seen this
perhaps he was he was hoping white would
fall for this
take on g2 how could you
yeah yeah yeah we'll do a little do a
little guessing I don't know I mean
maybe in this position I have 9a for you
want to take on f3 yeah you didn't even
look at my move
it's a good threat how did I see it okay
okay anybody else
okay in I assume all take us the initial
base like okay we AC
okay
and now mr. Burke it's a greenhorn it's
a bishop on the yeah okay okay I mean
we're getting up later yes nothing
special okay so if I take back
immediately
do you have something you're gonna
perpetual me you're gonna do this to me
yeah I mean Danny Pachuca who he finds
that draw so fast
you were here he couldn't wait for us
okay let's throw this in and now here
okay yeah yeah yeah this yeah yeah so if
you don't want to go there then you take
this and it's getting it's getting a
little bit dicey it's getting a little
bit dicey
I will return will return quickly to a
game there's I mean this is this is a
very complicated position and he did
find the right move here which is good I
mean there's just quite a lot of
potential here so yeah you couldn't move
the pieces and he didn't have a full
audience to help them out so the move is
first we take on f3 and if you take back
with the Queen which is the strongest
move then we take your Bishop on a7 and
you're borderline losing his white in
the game he took with the pawn and now
we we should be able to find the move
here
yeah all right there's two good moves
here so you can say either one probably
somebody really brilliant walked into
the room the guy that always comes in
with just the right answer at just the
right time ah
Mike calm er Mike comer to the rescue
you can also start with night takes a
seven the point is the same now you're
you're white the white queen is
overloaded so you can't defend here end
here and so black just want a piece and
making it a little bit worse on himself
he played Knight to d5 and now a very
nice tactical blow by black to really
really polish off this game Bishop d4
excellent and so now the queen is pin so
you're I'm gonna play Queen to g2 and
now right so now the game is just over
here so this is this was the last move a
very nice way to end the game and
congratulations on minis too many
mistakes yeah there was there's a lot of
inaccuracies in the middle game I think
white had it just the better position
straight out of the opening and he
didn't find a way to really open up the
position as quickly as possible to to
really cause problems to black black was
able to get all his pieces out he made
sort of the right decision he didn't
worry about his g6 pawn he just got his
Knight out and got all his pieces out
and okay the tactics ended up working
out for him a very well-played game I
think you should be be quite proud of
this one yeah yeah game 15 and okay even
with with an audience this large and
this high rated is still very difficult
to navigate all of these these
complicated lines and okay a very very
good job
you